if you want to be more charismatic and
you're looking for five ways and how to
do it then this video is for you
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and this
amazing gift that you have inside here
that I want to see explode out onto the
world instead of help you on your
journey today we're going to talk about
how you can be more charismatic
[Music]
how important is charisma and is it
necessary as a sales executive very
important yes so the reason I research
charisma is when I tell people there's
100 tools the knee-jerk reaction is okay
occur what's the most important tool
right people want to know what's the
most important tool and it's charisma
people want to be around you they want
to be influenced you there's very little
resistance and so I set out to find out
and interviewed charismatic salespeople
Kris mattock entrepreneur Chris Mannix
CEOs what did they have that the average
person didn't have and first of all you
already have some elements of charisma
and second of all the rest can be
learned and that's the key elements of
charisma that dramatically reduces
resistance and makes you very very
influential and it's something that can
be learned
no matter what I will be okay in my
opinion this is the most fundamental
mindset to charisma because so many
people live their life wrapped in this
sort of mental loop of what-if questions
right what if I speak up and my boss
doesn't like my idea what if I ask this
girl on a date and she says no or what
if I lean in for a kiss and even worse
she ducks away right what if I were to
ask this person to go just as a friend
out to coffee and they said I was busy
that day all of these sorts of things
stop people from acting from speaking up
from expressing who they really are now
in the social context what you need to
realize is that the repercussions for
even the worst case scenario of every
single one of these are not so bad you
recover from these if your boss doesn't
like the idea fine move on if a girl
doesn't want to go on a date with you
probably better that you know rather
than spending six months trying to
figure out which signals she's sending
that indicates that she does so when you
can get that mindset that no matter what
I will be okay and I apply this to the
social field I don't necessarily mean
that you need to extend this to jumping
out of 40 story buildings but socially
no matter what happens you will be okay
that enables you to act with this sort
of freedom that most people never ever
experience and that means that you can
risk social things in terms of cracking
jokes expressing ideas asking people
expressing how you feel that means that
you can risk that more than other people
and when other people see that you seem
to have this immunity to social pressure
that you're expressing who you are more
they will naturally gravitate towards
you because that is a strength that most
of us really really want to have in
ourselves the most fundamental peace no
matter what happens you will be okay if
you ever find yourself stuck not knowing
if you speak up come back to this belief
it is so critical if you see someone
who's depressed without me telling you
anything you could tell me that what
person has a physiology to them a way of
using their body what's their posture
like slumped where's their head down are
they breathing full or shallow you know
shallow do they talk really loud and
fast or more quiet and more hesitant in
order for us to feel any emotion anger
frustration uncertainty excitement we
have to use our body a certain one
emotion comes from emotion so most of us
have habits of using our body our breath
our movement our facial muscles we have
80 different muscles interphase 8 0 80
for most people this is the largest area
of unemployment in the country if you
want to change your life and you want to
be more assertive get around more
assertive people and model them take on
their posture move it seems artificial
and go stand with your hands on your
hips standing straight up if you stand
that way for 2 minutes like Superman
Wonder Woman within 2 minutes
the testosterone in you male or female
increases an average of 20% and the
cortisol which is the stress hormone
that stresses you out drops 15% in two
minutes and all you're doing is standing
like this and you're one-third more
likely to take action be more assertive
do something you normally wouldn't do
when you have confidence or we could
even call it fire when you have that
fire within you that confidence that
interior bravery you almost have this
power to do whatever it takes to get
your brave vision done you see in this
world it's not about you know in many
ways your strategy in your business or
your ability in your life it's about
this thing called confidence and we have
all had these times in our lives when we
are full of confidence and what other
people see is a problem we simply do see
as an opportunity other people see it as
a stumbling block block or a wall and we
see it as a stepping stone or this
solution and so confidence is sin thing
that you really want to wire in
conference is something you really want
to develop confidence is a practice
confidence is a muscle and like any
muscle the more you focus on it and
practice it and train it the stronger
your confidence is gonna grow so if an
entrepreneur is in my audience is mostly
entrepreneurs or wannabe entrepreneurs
trying to
business or get their business the next
step for an entrepreneur going into a
big meeting with a potential investor
potential customer that they you know
what they want to win that deal they
want to feel that influence what do you
recommend they do to get into that
mindset before going into the meeting
whatever it takes
see everyone's a little bit different
some people do affirmations my early
mentor Brian Tracy he was a big sales
guy he taught us to think I'm the best
I'm the best and that just didn't click
for me and so I just turned it around
like they owe me money they owe me money
and that worked for me
some people visualizing the sale some
people having a little ritual to get
them into the game for some people it's
being prepared and knowing their
material it might be all the above and
so everyone's a little bit different
here so people listen to music
some people pace I don't care but you
find the two of your things that work
for you you get in that zone feel
influential and become influential are
there are there recommendations you have
for how to find that thing you think we
already know it do you just recommend
cycling through a whole bunch of
different things to find it what do you
suggest I would cycle you know
remembering past victories I know for
everyone visualizing them saying yes
visualizing getting the sale works for
pretty much everybody and that's what's
interesting about mindset and self
persuasion that if you're stuck on worry
it's because your visions not strong
enough if you're worrying about this
what if they say no what if they don't
agree what if they don't do it you
haven't visualized the cell you haven't
in visualize the negotiation to to you
and your success so I encourage everyone
I know everyone that I've ever met
visualization works from you can see
yourself doing it it works because the
universe will not reward you physically
and so you can see it mentally
charismatic characteristic and number
five is being encouraging and uplifting
how hard is it to encourage somebody
great job you're amazing you're
incredible I really like you you're
great what a great pair of shoes you're
wearing compliments don't hurt either
but I'm telling you the simple act of
eliminating the negative speak and
mindset is one of the most critical
components of being charismatic you
do it you're amazing I believe in you
how hard was that wasn't hard at all
and how did you feel like exactly
amazing and I probably looked like I was
pretty damn charismatic and so can you
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you take in this video that you will
immediately apply somehow to your life
for your business what rule resonated
the most with you that just hit home the
hardest that you're going to apply leave
it down the comments below I'm really
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick chatted to Toni Toni thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and posting the link on
Twitter
I really really appreciate the support
man and I'm so glad you enjoyed the book
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
if you want to get stronger you can go
to the gym and if you're interested in
learning how to code there's tons of
classes and you can take on that but
where you go if you want to learn how to
develop your confidence and your
charisma so the first one is for the
type of person who might get into
conversation it feels like they very
quickly run out of things to say whether
that happens after a minute or after 20
minutes and the thing that I recommend
the class that I took that helped me the
most with that is improv comedy first
off because it is scary right to get up
there in front of a group of people you
don't know and try to be funny let alone
say anything is a terrifying experience
and anything that pushes your comfort
zone is going to help you in social
situations but that's not why I
recommend improv comedy in fact there's
something that is much much stronger
about that and that's that you have
nothing to go off of when you stand up
there you stand up there your mind is
blank and all of a sudden the audience
shouts out a suggestion and you have to
riff off that which might sound like
it's a very isolated incident but really
that's what all sorts of conversation
are you're talking to someone they give
you a conversational thread and then you
have to riff on that and that has helped
me more than anything I've ever done
continue conversations with people even
when they start to stall so check out
improv comedy if that's something that
you have identified as a problem in your
life smile often that charismatic people
know the power of the pearly whites and
they're not afraid to use them if you
want to be viewed as one charismatic
mother or you need the smile now one of
the issues that I hear a lot is guys
like yo I hate my grill I'm here to say
gentlemen that if you do if it is
preventing you from smiling save up the
money and get it fix races implants
orthodontic procedures veneers gentlemen
there are options out there are they
expensive some of them is it worth
saving up yes but regardless of the
quantity or quality of the teeth you
have in your mouth the one thing you can
do is keep them clean and white Nelson
Mandela is a particularly special case
study in the leadership world because he
is universally regarded as a great
leader
you can take other personalities and
depending on the nation you go to we
have different opinions about other
personalities but Nelson Mandela across
the world is universally regarded as a
great leader he was actually the son of
a tribal chief
and he was asked one day how did you
learn to be a great leader and he
responded that he would go with his
father to tribal meetings and he
remembers two things when his father
would meet with other elders one they
would always sit in a circle and to his
father was always the last to speak
you'll be told your whole life that you
need to learn to listen I would say that
you need to learn to be the last to
speak I see it in boardrooms every day
of the week even people who consider
themselves good leaders who may actually
be decent leaders will walk into a room
and say here's the problem here's what I
think but I'm interested in your opinion
let's go around the room it's too late
the skill to hold your opinions to
yourself until everyone has spoken does
two things one it gives everybody else
the feeling that they have been heard it
give me gives everyone else the ability
to feel that they have contributed and
two you get the benefit of hearing what
everybody else has to think before you
render your opinion the skill is really
to keep your opinions to yourself if you
agree with somebody don't nod yes if you
disagree with somebody don't nod no
simply sit there take it all in and the
only thing you're allowed to do is ask
questions so that you can understand
what they mean and why they have the
opinion that they have you must
understand from where they are speaking
why they have the opinion they have not
just what they are saying and at the end
you will get your turn it sounds easy
it's not practice being the last to
speak
that's what Nelson Mandela did wolves
long yeah
the most important work ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon they
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]